cinq heures de réunion avec la direction
pour avoir une seule certitude fin
juillet eolane à montceau les mines
c'est terminé seule note d'espoir six
repreneurs potentiels seraient peut-être
intéressés j'accorde un certain crédit à
direction dans le sens où elle a
consulté des entreprises qui pourraient
être preneur toute la difficulté c'est
de concrétiser sa est d'aboutir à une
reprise réelle spécialisée dans la
création de carte électronique eolane
possède 7 sites de production en france
le groupe participe même à l'effort
national pour produire des respirateurs
artificiels
mais malgré la crise du coc vie de 19 le
délai pour trouver un repreneur ne sera
pas allonger ce serait quand même
l'ironie du sort de voir notre site
disparaître juste avant une possibilité
d'euros nets grâce aux effets de la
crise de cornas virus
pourtant le pdg d olonne fait le choix
de se séparer d'un site qui selon lui ne
pourrait pas rapidement retrouvé une
activité rentable
on a mis combien de temps pour
délocaliser marine 2030 en enregistrait
connaîtra pas 30 ans pour relocaliser
mais c'est dans l'échelle de temps si
vous l'étiez qui est qui qui serait la
solution de montceau sur le parking
salariés et élus ont le sentiment d'être
depuis un an
mené en bateau mais nous amuse n'y a pas
si longtemps que ça il y disait qu'il y
croyait pas à la reprise et que
maintenant une chance c'est pour nous
amadouer un petit peu que la direction
générale des eaux lan qui est une
société française décide
envers et contre tous je dis bien envers
et contre tous de fermer le site de
montceau c'est inacceptable parce que il
n'y a aucune raison économique et aucune
raison aux tables financière de fermer
ce site salariés élus comptent
interpeller directement le ministère de
l'économie
80 emplois sont en jeu dans un bassin
déjà fortement touchés par les
fermetures d'entreprises